hello guys I'm Ryan right Melissa for
Melissa be crazy
so listen be crazy and I she's gonna
help me unbox we're gone 1up box today
so I forgot what month in theme this is
I know but just tell me what it what it
says what's what's the theme okay so if
nightmare haha nightmare makes sense
yeah all right now just alright let's
open this [ __ ] [ __ ] is this lanyard yeah
I don't understand though you you link
one of it to something yeah what is this
though what makes what makes this all
one up boxy special oh cool oh in the
dark one yeah you're smart it's all in
your noggin on your noggin and you carry
it in your breast disease too
it's true once I can tell if the weather
is good as the other you can tell if
it's raining yeah same thing with my
testicles whoo yeah we could also use
this as another toy Veronica I found a
toy for us it's like it moves like a
snake yeah next one I've no idea
looks like it's a poster ooh contouring
ghastly pointed out ponder ghastly and
then there's other people on there and I
see Luigi I think that's Kid Icarus but
I'm not 100% positive Sally and Jack and
Boop
Sally and Jack and Boo yeah yes
oh no way that's adorable a jack
skeleton figure keychain from pop I have
some these are my favorite ones whenever
I get these I like collecting them
I feel like everyone's into pop figures
now they're the things like they're like
both people they're like the new Pokemon
in some ways yeah
only they appeal to like every fandom
they appeal to most people just
depending yes
shut up Alyssa yes Daryl keychain from
the walking dead
- oh there's tiered here yeah this one
though I'm yep
I'm definitely rocking this one oh yeah
yeah cool that is got a miniature Daryl
here pin then it's Donatello zombie tell
oh yeah that's pretty that's a great way
to ruin a child's name you know just
like hey here's a creepy version of her
favorite beloved Ninja Turtle sleeping
mask boom I got a sleeping mask now baby
don't sneeze in them on my video don't
cease in the middle might be don't
sneeze in the middle of my videos look
like when I sleep now it's a scurry and
pop rocks pop rocks oh I live it on the
edge
I put too many pop rocks in my mouth
yeah okay go on for a while I know all
right here we go
look they're not 100 that's so cool
Quadra catholic agar luigi are a people
are it's like Luigi's Mansion theme yeah
this is so cool
you know Mario had here - oh all right
that's so cool
you get so many cool shirts I think they
got like some of the best the [ __ ] is
this this is huge
anyway look how cool that looks huh
really cool more fun stuff for me too
because I want them to all glow in the
dark anyway guys if you guys want a 1up
box to be as cool as this [ __ ]
this city slicker over here I just
thought I Love You Man again if you want
to be as cool as me get a 1-up bucks
today and you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter vine and periscope
subscribe to the real rejects check out
Alyssa be crazy and have yourself a good
day people enjoy yourself today and if
it means touching yourself that's okay
that's also okay just make sure you have
time to take a nap afterwards and just
if you do it in public just be courteous
yeah unless you know you find someone
public who's into it Nick how do you
think we met very awkward situation
really really awkward and amazed yeah
yeah did pepper sprayed me right away
with bear spray yeah it was bad